welcome back to ET everybody okay I
cannot wait to get to this big
announcement because this is huge
Brad Pitt is a new property brother did
he's property brother from another we
all have the same amps yeah which is
actually surprising a lot of people
don't know he is so into architecture
he's brilliant when it come home I will
admit when we were doing a little demo
he beat it he beat me through the wall
like he smashed through that thing like
no one's business you know people out
there are probably saying wait wait what
are you talking about Brad Pitt's
working with them tell us about this new
show celebrity I owe you basically we
partner with huge celebrities from all
different walks of life musicians actors
you name it and they want to give back
to somebody who's been really important
in their life and and they partner with
us to make that happen so Brad picked is
makeup artist right that's right
jeans been with him for over thirty
years when you see them together it's
almost like they're two kids that's
really good I hear that Melissa McCarthy
may be good with a power tool or two oh
my gosh yeah there's nothing that she
would back away from by the way drew can
we talk about a photo that you just put
up not too long ago photo on set the
caption baby practice on the set what is
going on no do I look like I know what
I'm doing you do yeah because that's not
a real baby listen this is Entertainment
Tonight you and Linda can announce
anything you want right here right get
me a camera all right I'm gonna say to
you right now I don't have a baby yet
but I'll let you know what's coming I
loved the carpool karaoke with you guys
I think we talked about that a little
bit I like the team they with Zoe and
her sister there were sparks right away
during that like and then I was playing
it super cool
you're putting her place initially you
know I was like I was playing it cool it
is fine and you know I looked at the
episode when we screened it and it
looked like Zoey was flirting with me on
the episode and I was like whoa see I
was playing it cool the producer saw
he's like no no even flirting so bad we
had to edit it down yeah it's got
families a tight family so how was she
received she can literally never do any
wrong in my dad's eyes because first
time she was meeting mom and dad via
FaceTime
she sang my dad's favorite song she's
saying Danny Boy and my dad literally
teared up and and then after my mom
Texas says she's perfect go on carpool
karaoke cuz it worked yes
[Music]